there's a thing called dopamine reward
prediction error if you think the reward
is coming and it doesn't you drop below
Baseline levels of dopamine that's why
you should never tell someone that this
restaurant's going to be the best
restaurant you've ever been to in your
life exactly I made the mistake of
telling my girlfriend on the way here I
want her to read this book I'm like this
is an amazing book you should read it
and I caught myself and I thought damn
it I'm actually detracting from how good
she's going to experience the book tell
her it was terrible it's really good
though this is the problem it's hard to
do it's not an argument to be made that
you would be able to drag out the amount
of time that dopamine is released for
because of the anticipation anticipation
is the kind of ultimate fuel of the
courting dance but one has to be very
careful because whether or not it's from
the male side of the female side or
whatever variation they're of you only
get so many reward prediction errors
before people start to associate low
dopamine with somebody or some
experience you can only create positive
anticipation so many times and then
create a letdown before delivery of the
promise has very little impact and so
you have to be very careful with one's
words